voilà pour ce portrait de seigneurs donc
et puis l'autre histoire dans le sud de
la france
c'est une histoire d'amour un amour foot
qui dure depuis soixante dix ans entre
ces deux là qui fêtent leurs noces de
platine
tout a commencé à l'om avant la guerre
reportage à marseille claude crise
paupières moscovitch
les héros de cette histoire marseillaise
ont des prénoms impériaux auguste et
marie thérèse il ya quelques semaines le
couple a fêté ses noces de platine
soixante dix ans ensemble si au but
aujourd'hui est un peu perdu dans ses
rêves
marie thérèse est toujours aussi tonique
une mémoire incroyable qu'elle peut
faire remonter jusqu'en 1929 quand elle
jouait au football bien sûr au sein de
l'om en tant que capitaine jouer leurs
droits
six mois qui marquait des buts de la
tête et du pied l'école du sort et
enjoué par n'importe quel temps le froid
le vent la neige car elles marchent en
était là au cul ce n'est pas en reste
il a même été champion de france en 1929
d'où d'ailleurs cet hommage de pierre au
musée de l'om toutes les gloires
phocéenne du ballon rond anciennes et
plus récentes ont laissé leur empreinte
et le premier de la liste est auguste à
coyron que découvre son fils avec
émotion c'est donc un ballon de cuir qui
réunit auguste et marie thérèse ya
soixante dix ans après une rencontre ici
au stade vélodrome football les
supporters se retrouver pour danser
j'étais pas mal à ça c'est beaucoup et
c'est par la danse pour la plupart
l'échangé des idées
augusta aujourd'hui 96 ans entre temps
il aura fait trois beaux enfants marie
thérèse et continuera de pratiquer le
football
quelques années encore comme entraîneur
aujourd'hui il reste une référence à
marseille même si le football a beaucoup
évolué entre générations ou jouer à
l'inspiration
alors qu'aujourd'hui dans le
professionnalisme c'est beaucoup plus
technique c'est beaucoup plus pointu
trois enfants cinq petits-enfants huit
arrière petits enfants
la preuve que l'on peut concilier sport
et bonheur